All right.
Good afternoon yogurts and Googlers.
I'm delighted to welcome
to the Google campus,
one of the most celebrated
names in Bollywood today.
She'll pass shatty Chondra.
She'll bus an actress,
producer, former model.
She's the winner of the
British reality TV show,
celebrity big brother five and has been
nominated for four film fair awards and
all the year she's delighted us with
her acting and dancing and mostly Hindi
movies, but also Tamil, Telugu
and Canada. But more importantly,
she has this passion for the auto wellness
and how we can transform ourselves
inside out through modalities like yoga,
meditation,
or good nutrition, which is one of the
main topics she wants to share with us.
And if you get lucky, she might actually
lead us through a short yoga practice.
So please help me with a Bollywood style.
Welcome to [inaudible].
She'll fuck.
Wow.
What an amazing introduction and
from the Yogi himself ameliorated.
Thank you so much.
Thank you.
And I'm not saying welcome Shilpa.
Wow.
I want to Google.
This is Bob
with the yoga practice
and Googlers called Yoga.
I know yo gloves. How wonderful is
that? So all of you actually do yoga.
That's terrible.
Well guys, let's, let's
hope we can change that.
So if I do come in next time,
let's see more people saying
yes to that confidently.
Yeah,
no, we have a pretty active program
with the several hundred classes a week,
just in the San Francisco Bay area alone.
We have 50 classes every week and they're
pretty packed. But on your channel,
one of your signature
[inaudible] master hall, right?
We've got to make everyone do that.
So can you demonstrate it once and then
I'll get the whole audience with Joe in
a couple of times?
What do you say?
So swaths through a whole muster all
means stay healthy and just throw caution
to the wind and just be happy.
So that truly is my mantra in life.
Uh,
stay happy and stay busts. So
I do it like this, so I slow.
All right, let's do it with a
couple of times. Do it again.
One more time. A little louder.
Slas with the Ham hocks throw.
Thank you. Nobody. You can
see my biceps, but yeah.
So I understand you're here for a
woman's empowerment conference. Yes.
How did that go? And, uh,
what is your vision for
empowering women around the world?
Oh my God. Um, yeah, that went
really well. I've, I've just still,
I mean we're close to, you know,
women's Day on the 8th of March.
I thought this was a great opportunity
and when I was offered it, I said, great,
I'll tour around the U S and.
M.
More importantly I think,
um,
since I've just started this wellness
series are through digital media,
I just star,
I just thought this would
be a great opportunity also
to come and visit you guys,
learn from you and help.
I'd rather get help from you
to help me help the world.
And, uh, you know, I've been
acting for the last 20 years,
but this truly is my colleague.
I really believe that I became an actor
and I became someone who was famous so
that I could be of some
use in this sphere.
And, um, I, for me, health
is truly my passion.
I have suffered with cervical spondylosis
as seen people who are not near and
dear to me suffer with cancer.
And um,
I've been able to change
my life through yoga,
through meditation or
through good eating habits,
which I call the lifestyle modification.
I never use the word Diet because
I think it's just so vulgar.
Vulgarized that word Diet that the minute
you say diet, people are put off by it.
They think it's going to be bland food.
It's not going to be tasty.
It's going to be sodium, less oil lists.
So I said, how do I,
how do I debunk these,
these meats with food health?
And um,
there are, there is a lot of
information on Google. Great.
I just thought I'd make,
make it easier to China to kind of make
it a one stop shop for people or who
really can't afford a gym,
don't have the time to work out,
don't know what to cook
for their children. Um,
and I just think that women especially
are already in such an empowered
position. You know, since we're
talking about empowerment,
I thought to just give them the knowledge
of and empower them with the knowledge
of health,
uh,
which I think is something that is
far more powerful than the feminists.
Sort of empowering, you know, um,
I thought through my channel I'd be able
to channelize a bit of my knowledge to
the experts that I have on my channel
to be able to empower people with the
importance of health. How
important it is to breed. Yeah.
Which we're not doing
in this time and age.
We're so busy running after our goals
up or not breathing or forget doing
primas. How many of you actually sit
down and take a breath of fresh air?
Very few. Yeah, you do. Yes. You know,
I'm not directing the question to you,
but none of us sit down
and just inhale and exhale.
We don't do that. You know, our chest is
an opening. Okay. Teach them right now.
Let's change that. How do
you do it? Nope. Just leave.
Just open up, you know,
positivity
or negativity. Trust
me, there's lots of it.
Okay.
And when you're inhaling and exhaling,
you're not doing it just
from your chest in your body.
You're doing it from your mind.
So it's your entire mind and
soul that is getting purified.
You know,
oxygen is reaching your lungs and it's
purifying your body and your mind.
It opens up your mind and all
the space that you guys are in.
Trust me, it's going to help you a lot.
You need your mind. You're like Yolo,
mind workers.
And uh,
I just think that small little things
like that. Breathing, chewing food,
chewing food. How many of us to our food
study got to chew our food 32 times.
Each muscle has to be true 32 times as
why you would do that. Because that's,
that's the reason beginning
given 32 teens, none of us do it.
We just,
which has got Bullitt,
we've started gobbling off food.
We've stopped.
We don't even concentrate
on what we eating.
How many of you look at your food with
gratitude and see, oh my God, wow,
this is going into my body.
None of us do it. You do it.
That's why you look so big in the pink
of health. He looks well nourished. Yeah.
So we know you don't, we just have
stopped living. We, we're just living,
we've been not enjoying our life.
And I just think that,
you know,
before it gets too late,
because I've lost a few
people that I love very dirty,
all to bad health.
And I just felt that it was important for
me to take this off as a cause. I mean,
we, you know, I've worked
with HIV patients and uh,
I've done something and you know, in that
sphere of, of health and I'm like, Gosh,
what if we could actually just rewind.
I live better lives,
you know,
rather than reach a point of no return.
We own to,
you know, vitamin injections. Today
we're all d three deficient. Most of us,
80% of us are d three deficient because
we don't want to stand out in the sun.
So I'm like, um, small little things.
I just think I want to bring focus to
the old way of living and I want to do
that through this jungle.
And it really comes out of out of
my heart and less from my mind,
and I've said this before,
I just saw the world is going digital
and I thought let me do it this way
because it'll reach out to
more people are really happy.
Then the day we launched we,
we touched all the nearly 1.5 views,
yes million views and it was a huge
compliment and also reassuring that people
are interested in health.
I don't know if they just want
her to see shows by Shanti Lycra,
but that couldn't have been the only
reason. So we have a few subscribers now.
We've touched nearly 67 k
so health, wellness and how to
uh, one of the popular category,
all the questions he doesn't know.
But one of the accomplishments we are
very proud of among everything else is
that you choose to be
what we call a youtuber.
You've chosen the platform that is
more than a billion people coming and
watching some video the other every month.
Yeah.
So in fact the audience
may not have seen it.
Can we roll a video just to show everyone
a rules paste of what she'll pass
channel looks like on Youtube.
Hello everyone.
I'm here to tell you why I'm here
and what this channel is all about.
Out of the various things
that I've done in life.
The reason to start this journal is to
bring about an awareness for what I value
the most life.
How many of us do we really value life?
Why is the quality of
our health deteriorating?
Why do we have to stay dependent
on artificial aids like medication,
vitamin injections and succumb
to deficiencies, diseases,
deteriorating immunity and jeans?
The answers to all these questions
like in one important fact,
our constant neglect,
an apathy towards our own health.
The target of this channel is to address
both weight as well as health issues.
Those who cannot afford
a gym or nutritionists or
don't have the time for the
regime will be introduced to a panel
of experts in various fields of health
along with my limited knowledge
and experience to make the change.
Please subscribe to the shield bash
at each channel, what you will find.
Quick healthy and tasty
food recipes made by me.
Yoga Asanas,
simple fitness routines and challenges
along the way with weight loss targets.
Remember, there is no better time
than now to start living healthy.
Maintaining your weight
and keeping fit is an art.
And the artists keep it simple.
We'll show you how.
One last thing [inaudible] unless throat.
I didn't know they were going
to play that. Gosh, I give
the hood speed on my own.
I, if I knew they were
going to have to speak. So
repetition is good.
So I have two questions.
Where you up first is how the experience
with Youtube and then secondly you've
got one on some of the smartest
youtube folks sitting right here.
Do you have any ask for them?
Yes.
Yeah,
I want to ask them to help me.
Um,
obviously I'd love to hear from you how
I could popularize this and I realize
why.
I think I'm one of the first celebrities
are to be a youtuber because it takes
so long, it takes so much time. You know,
we're such a pampered lot and also
spoiled in the way that we paid for every
minute. And this is something
that I'm doing free and, and I'm,
I'm seeing this song
with a lot of humility.
So I realize when I embarked on this
venture or this journey that I taught,
you know, I just shoot and I'll
just start putting up stuff.
But it wasn't that easy.
There was, you know,
there was work going into
what we supposed to shoot,
what we supposed to actually put out or
targeting all the important questions or
as a Lima and what is it that, you
know, how do we start off? How do we,
you don't keep that interest going.
What is the first thing that
would catch people's eyes and uh,
or imagination,
how do we get them interested in health?
It was so much homework and
then the hours of shooting,
eight hours of, of doing yoga. Yeah.
Eight hours every shoot of
doing, you know, six hours.
I couldn't do beyond that because I
started cramping. Yeah. And you know,
when you do yoga you can't eat.
So I was on,
I was just sipping on
liquids and you know, fruit.
So I shoots would begin at like nine in
the morning and I'd have to keep light.
So you fully enlightened by evening? No.
So I understand what the beauty of it is.
I discovered,
I discovered so much through that
journey because I mean when you do yoga,
you don't do it beyond an hour,
but at the shoot,
because I obviously wanted to,
you know,
do my best and I wanted to do every Asana,
Asana to my optimum best
because I wanted people to,
oh, you know, to,
to realize that this is
what you can achieve or,
so I didn't know I had
that kind of strength.
I didn't know that I could actually
stay without food for six hours.
Yeah. And it's, that's the power of yoga.
It truly is mind over body.
Absolutely.
And so do the shoot would,
would go on, I'd be okay.
And soon as the shoot was over I'd
be like, I give me anything to eat.
So that is amazing. And then also the
cooking. So we didn't have a food stylist.
It's youtube. We were really good,
deep goody baseball. So, so be like,
you know, cost cutting. I said we can't
afford me. This is not a normal shoot.
So everything from cutting
the vegetables to euro,
I'm putting it on the plate
and showing it to people.
I've done it all my self.
So,
and it was,
and we did nearly like eight,
eight dishes a day because
we wanted a bank before we,
we started rolling. Yeah. And
the minute we had like 60,
70 videos in hand,
that's when I launched it.
But the work has been going on
for the last nine months. So,
uh, it was a lot of hard work
and that's when I realized,
and then after you finished it,
I also had to debate.
So every asinine is dubbed by me.
So it was a lot of hard
work. So I realized why no
celebrity wants to do this.
I was like,
good gracious God.
So that's great feedback and we'll take
it away and we happy to share some best
practices with you.
But one suggestion is actually that behind
the scene story you just told me that
it still will make for an interesting
episode because people want to hear that.
Your fans want to hear that.
So go back and relive the production.
There's one more video.
Crazy. Um, but what
did you take out of it?
I want to know from you because you
are a Yogi yourself and you're very
passionate.
Yeah. So my biggest takeaway
is when I was a kid,
I ran away to an Ashram
and I had to learn yoga.
And we are primarily taught
by bearded men and orange.
It was an esoteric practice
and thanks to now supermodels,
super actresses turned Super Yogi knees.
It's become more accessible
to a larger population in the,
it's got demystified and you frame it in
more contemporary terms and you make it
accessible to a lot of people otherwise
who would not have looked at it.
So I want to thank you for doing it.
You and I want to thank you that,
you know,
you're in San Francisco and
you're such a, you know, uh,
diligent follower of yoga and
you're trying to spread the word,
which is really wonderful.
So huge round of applause.
Thank you.
[inaudible].
So speaking of one yoga, one question
and then we'll go into a practice mode.
Bollywood is not exactly the right
environment for a yoga mindfulness kind of
practice.
It's a frenzy,
plays things more quickly and there's a
lot of tension and stress and a lot of
travel. So how do you reconcile those
two worlds and bring it together?
That's a really interesting question.
Um,
that's why I'm not doing movies right now.
I haven't done for the last
seven years.
I think maybe nine,
but I'm still here.
I'm still at Google and uh,
I've made my choices. I've
been there, done that.
I've been been part of the menu
for the last years. Um, I do,
I do TV.
I choose to do that because I can't
be part of this or erotic timings.
And you know, I have, I have a
four and a half year old baby.
And for me I'm very clear that that is my,
he is my priority,
my family is my first priority and
I want to give time to myself and
unapologetically.
And when you're an actor,
it's very hard to do that. So, I mean,
obviously my recognition
comes through movies.
That will always be my claim to
fame. I'm very proud of it. Um,
but if, if I do choose
to do a movie, it'll be,
it'll have to work around my schedule.
We'll have to,
we'll have to be a film that is, you
know, that'll start an end quickly. Also,
I think I turned to yoga because of,
of the frenzy life that we lead.
Um,
it's,
it's a very hard life.
You're constantly living in
a glass fish bowl and um,
you're getting trolled.
Um,
Instagram determines how famous you are,
how much you liked.
It's, it's, it's really shallow. And
though I have to say in the most hippo
and hypocritical sort of way that I love
that. I love it. I really do. Uh,
but the time that I share with myself,
that for me
is just, it's just my time. You know,
it just helps me cope with everything.
So even if I'm told and if
somebody writes about that article,
it's just, that's part of
my life. The morning that I
wake up and I do my plan, I,
Emma and I'm in the sun, basking
in its glory and my feet are tired,
you know, my feet is formally
on the grass that is life,
you know, just, just
being able to do that,
to breathe the air and to just
live this blessed life for me,
that is far more important than all the,
you know,
the craziness of,
of our job.
So I think that's what keeps me grounded.
So a lot of people tell me,
how do you manage to be,
you know,
so positive and you're
like smiling. I have, I,
I get upset. I'm only human.
Of course I get upset.
Of course. I, uh, I go
to my times of, you know,
why would they write something like that?
But then I'm out of it.
I don't carry forward. And I think
help yoga has helped me do that.
Yoga has made me
believe that what cannot
be cured has to be endured.
And that is once you understand that
all life is so much more easier.
Otherwise being an actor as a really hard
job that'd be telling you to be bought
of it for the last 23 years has been,
I don't know how,
I don't know how I've lost it on so long.
We'll do yoga, meditation really, really,
and I, Oh, I'm jet lagged.
I have traveled all the way
from India. It's, and I've,
I've done Orlando and I've come, I've
come here, I've done an event last night.
A baby slept like seven hours.
But uh,
I got up and I just went out in the open
and I just did a couple of breathing
exercises and I'm good to go.
Fantastic. So would you lead us
through a practice and make us do that?
I got one more thing for you.
We can't have Shilpa shatty here
and not do a little phone card.
That's like
having Michael Jordan
here and we'll slam dunk.
So teach us how to do the Tem Cup.
Oh,
can we have some music?
Be Embarrassing
for all of the respect that I bought.
It's only on Youtube. So only a
billion people will be watching it.
Yeah. Lovely. Yeah.
All right, so everybody stand up.
We need music. Yeah, he's actually,
he's playing some music for us on this.
Okay.
How do we do this?
Go.
Okay.
This is out of my faucet.
Yeah.
I thought this office
is, that'd be one thing,
but what's occupants?
We did a few more people joining you,
right?
How many people want to dance with you?
If I said it took crime?
Come on to your sites.
Get onto your site and now come up.
Yeah,
sit up.
Yeah. We can all sit in Sukhasana. Okay.
If y'all don't know what that means,
just one leg up. Still Cost
Center. So comedians happiness.
So it's the Austin of happiness.
When you order this us center,
the entire concentration is on your core.
That's where all our strength lies.
Our core.
Oh,
what is [inaudible]? Most
importantly, before we start,
for all those people who don't
know the meaning of [inaudible],
Purana means life.
And Yama
means control.
So the god of death is called
Yama cause he could draw his life.
So Proud Ima actually is the
control of your life force,
which happens to breadth.
So when they see a in your breadth,
you all controlling your mind through that
ad.
When your mind is in control,
there's nothing that you
cannot achieve in life.
So most importantly, while most
blood, we need such fast paced lives,
even if we don't get the
time to do all the Asanas,
if we just get the time to
just do a few bright I umas,
it takes 10 minutes.
I have 10 minutes.
Can actually, Elaine can
actually align your mind, body,
and soul.
What would life would be so worth living?
So we'll start off with the simple
technique of just inhaling and exhaling
through your nose, okay? When you inhale,
let your chest open out,
okay.
Okay.
And Yada withdraw.
They say this is a Moodra of width.
Wisdom.
Your heart and your mind are aligned
on your knees.
Taking a deep breath.
Exhale.
Deep breath in.
One small.
Yeah.
Wonderful.
We started off with unknown Valone where
we taking the bread through the left
nostril. Okay, so this is your
hand. Just keep it simple.
Okay. There's a more
complicated way of doing it.
I'm going to keep it simple for you guys.
This the index and this thing. Good dog.
Alright. The pommel. Okay,
well you can even do this, right,
so you basically need to control.
Yeah. Tom, on your right nostril.
Breathe in through your left.
I'll do it once. View. Okay,
thanks. See you in through the right.
Then you inhale again through the right.
Exhale through the left.
Inhale through the left.
Thanks. See you in through
the right. Get that.
So this is a new low and
below. We'll start. Okay.
We do five of these,
right? Go Pt up, Connie.
I, I'll be RP that I use
it. Do you not do this?
He's far more loaded than me. He's been
doing yoga for so much, so much time.
[inaudible] like if you can be in an
Austin now for more than an hour and a
half, you like Judy going to teen
Cindy, you become a true Yogi.
If you can be in a post for three hours.
I haven't reached that stage gate,
so I'm not yet quantified Yogi
eight hour shoot again. Yeah, yeah.
It's still no what? I still couldn't be
in one asset and over like three hours,
so I'm going to let you lead the class.
That's my respect for,
you know you want to
love from no, no, no, no.
I want you to take the glass cupboard.
Ready?
Reading through the left.
Okay.
Breathe out through the right.
Inhale and exhale long breadth.
There's no hurry.
Breathe in from the same
nostra that you've exhaled.
Breathe out through the left.
Yeah.
Breathe in through the left.
Breathe out through the right.
Breathe in through the right. Sorry,
I'm not very good at this.
Breathe out through the left.
Okay.
Breathe in through the left.
Breathe out through the right.
Okay.
Breathe in through the right.
Three dots through the left,
the last one.
Breathe in through the left.
Breathe out through the right,
breathe in through the right,
pre out, holy, completely
through the left.
Come into the [inaudible]
eyes closed,
concentrating on the
center of your forehead.
The agenda Chakra.
Throw all your Google as this
is the most important Chakra.
Yeah,
that's you concentrate.
And the Sahasrara Chakra,
which is right above that,
the center of your head.
Open up your mind.
Just breathe.
Open your eyes slowly
and I'll redo cabal Bahati.
[inaudible] is going to explain the
method of Capalaba, but they do,
cause he's done many El classes.
You'll basically,
yeah,
it's a breathing technique
where you pump your lungs,
talk about forcefully exhaling and
lift the inhalation come in naturally.
So one way to get a feel as police,
your right hand on your abdomen,
meaning see it forcefully, just policemen,
sports. I'm thinking, Holy Shit.
You can just let it naturally.
Then you'd do a CV.
We do sets of 20 okay,
we'll do two sets of 20 you
have to imagine like if you,
what if it's a small little
insect has gone into your nose,
how would you take it out?
Yeah.
Yup. That's one way of
explaining it. Yeah. Never know.
Doing Yoga. 20 insects. Yeah.
Blue or 20 insects and you have to
feel the air be bumped from the center.
Okay.
And what this technique does,
it's a Brene cleansing technique.
It's a very,
very powerful technique
and a ball for Pranayama.
So we start
hands on your one hand on your navel.
The center. Yup. Take a deep breath in.
Won. Won. Won, won, won. Won. Won.
Won. Won, won. Great. Excellent.
Thanks. Thanks. Thanks.
So you're doing it the opposite
way. It's not. It's out.
So that's the movement.
Yeah.
No, no. You don't have
to move your entire body.
It's only the breadth and your
stomach that moves towards no,
no.
Your Body's upright align your chakras.
You have to align your back straight.
Have you do it again.
Everybody coming to
get your breath together.
Take a breath in.
Good job.
Very nice.
Wonderful.
I know a lot of you
have just started out so
you would require a little more,
but this is a great technique
to cleanse your nasal passage.
I'm down with a bad cool takes to
San Francisco. I was out last night,
but I'll,
this is a great way to cleanse your,
your brain to oxygenate your lungs
all.
You suddenly start feeling a glow on
your face when you continue with this
practice for maybe a month.
If you do it every day,
these three parameters,
if you can do everyday or
maybe four times a week,
you will see the difference that it
will have in your life on your life.
So I always see that
fitness is like a marriage.
You can't cheat on it
and expect it to work.
So you have to give it
some amount of your time,
commitment and love.
So
do you want to continue? Should
we do go into Shavasana? Awesome.
Yeah, you tell me it's in a mascot.
We're going to be too difficult for them.
It's like,
Dude,
oh,
[inaudible] Angelo Minnow and just
breathe in, breathe out plastic,
no bus because a little more complicated.
So I, I, you know, when you start off,
you start with ABCD would start with Xyz.
So just these three concentrating
on your breath for 15 minutes.
Can I get a tissue and even here,
okay.
I normally never start
with a or with a student.
I'm a scar with people who
have just started to learn
because I feel you need to
spot them and make sure that they're going
in the right position when they're in
downward dog. I don't want
anybody in doing so I'm going
to show it. Yeah. Lovely.
Got It.
First and foremost, before you get down
to doing the sooner and the postcard,
we have to do a stretch.
Yoga is about action reaction.
So every stat stretch
has a counter stretch.
So before starting,
just losing every part of your
body just to shake it all up.
Just shake it all up and
yeah,
just like just move. Yeah,
just every part is like,
it's like a dog yard. Just, yeah, just,
just warm your body up.
Yeah.
Just kick your legs around.
We'll just do the next rotation
cause it's very important to warm up.
I cannot be more emphasis
on warmups or never do.
I'll never get into a regime or an
exercise routine without a warmup.
So you just look to your right first
center slowly
to the left
center.
Look straight up.
Try and go as behind as you can stretch
your neck and you come down the same
way.
Try to touch your chin to your chest,
right in the center. Straight
ahead. Rotate your neck. Now
three times
looking towards your right.
Come to the center
three times on the opposite side.
I'll be going to thought Asana.
Okay. Are you standing like a tree?
Hands up
dry and Dutch skies on your toes.
Open up to your chest.
Breed
down on the side.
Come down.
Do the same thing again.
Going to noma.
Stay right on top.
Stretch.
Yeah.
Dawn, tragic. Dot.
Should fingers to the ground.
Now breathe out.
Breathe in.
Come up.
Can we do that again? How many you
do it the second time? Trust me,
you will go down low.
Hands Up,
exit.
Come up.
Hands on the side.
Come down.
We do the suit. Have a
scar. Heady Chile. Oh,
lovely.
I'll be doing the sooner that was
come. Let's do it together then. Yeah,
make sure that the breathing technique
is right. So with every Arsenault reading
without one leg behind.
Yeah,
just light up just to the floor first,
which I haven't got cinema.
Now you get into downward dog.
Make sure that their
heels touch the ground.
Try to go towards your dealer.
One legged front.
Then the next
come up slowly
adds up.
It did. I must stay. How
did that make you feel?
Awesome, right? Let's do
that now in one go. Yeah,
you got the technique ready.
Ends up going backwards.
Down.
Butt Up.
Only me starts the flow.
Downward dog.
Let's do three of these. One more. Okay.
Heads up.
That's fantastic.
Make sure when you go down that position,
I feel most people do it
wrong and you go down.
When you are here,
make sure you go down like this.
This is the right way to do it.
Most people do this.
That's not the right way,
so only your,
this is the way.
Then you come up and then you
go do this in downward dog.
Try and always
concentrate and go backwards.
Okay? I just showed it to him was when you
guys do it, you need to get this right.
Okay.
We just do one more fastener.
We do the bead Asana, which is my
favorite Asana. It's great for the legs.
Okay.
Feet, hip width. The Bot. Yeah.
Lovely. Now your turn. One leg
hands on the side
that's on top bend
breeds. You should feel
the tension in your glutes,
on your ties.
Come up,
turn to the other side.
Come up.
Center.
Hands on the side.
Yeah.
Yay. That felt great. Thank you.
Thank you. Thank you.
She'll buffer. Wonderful Clap. Thank
you. Thank you. Thank you so much.